Sustainability is a really broad scope
of,
of dealing with,
with conflict or with issues or
challenges that come across,
um,
in the more developed countries,
you know,
we'll look at how we avoid abusing the
environment and how we can build a
buildings in a green sustainable
standards and we're very advanced on
that,
on that side.
But if you go to Africa to countries,
um,
you know,
like Uganda and Nigeria and Ghana and if
you go to Central America,
you know,
the basic needs of sustainability
sometimes is to teach the basic hygiene
for,
for children,
giving them a toothbrush and,
and,
and explaining them how to cross the
roads for safety,
which is something that they're not
familiar because they live in distant
and rural Arrow and working with the
community around what is important for
them as part of their sustainability,
how they build their capabilities over
time.
Whether again this is more of a health
care issues,
education around topics and we embrace
the environmental issues into these,
these ideas,
but in a very soft way.
So there is a big difference for
sustainability in the developed or in
the third world countries.
And in the developed world,
we're doing these big water project in
the Bahamas.
It's a $90,000,000 project on reducing
water leakage in the system.
Over 10 year period,
we will reduce the water leakage from 50
percent to 25 percent.
And we've been doing a lot of work
around education of people working with
schools,
working with children about the
importance of water,
about the importance of saving water,
about creating the awareness of why
water or are so crucial in our life.
Why clean water are so crucial in our
life.
This is sustainability for these
specific citizens in this specific area
of the world.
So you can combine the message according
to what you do and according to what the
people on the ground needs and these
things being been very successful.
You can save a lot of money,
not only water,
but a lot of money for these schools and
for these families.
If you make and create the awareness and
education programs around that.